hello everyone and welcome to today's
live broadcast how your lab is
sacrificing safety and spending too much
money
presented by Brian Garrett yes the LEED
Green Associate product manager at lab
crown Co Corporation we are excited to
bring you this educational web seminar
presented by labyrinth and sponsored by
lab con co serving in scientific
community since 1925 lab Conoco
manufactures laboratory equipment
specializing in ventilation products
such as chemical fume hoods and
biological safety cabinets they also
produce other lab equipment such as
glassware washers and freeze dryers lab
con co has ISO 9001 certification one
measure of the company's commitment to
quality and consistency is mine and
manufacturing lab control equipment is
manufactured in Kansas City Missouri and
Fort Scott Kansas and marketed worldwide
to academic industrial life science
pharmaceutical environmental forensic
and Clinical Laboratory to learn more
about lab con cokes please visit WWE
Champion hi I'm Camille Rocko blabbers
and I'll be your moderator for today's
event this webinar has been approved for
continuing educational credits please
click on the see e button at the bottom
left corner and follow the process to
receive your credits before we begin I
would like to remind everyone this event
is interactive and we encourage you to
participate by submitting as many
questions as you want anytime you want
during the presentation just click on
the green Q&A button located in the
lower left of the presentation window
type your question into the box it
appears on the screen will answer as
many questions as we have time for at
the end of the presentation
also if you notice you'll be viewing the
presentation in the slide window to
enlarge the window just click on the
screen icon located on the lower right
and finally if you have trouble seeing
or hearing the presentation click on the
support button at the top right of the
presentation window or you can use the
Q&A button to let us know you're having
a problem thank you
now I'd like to introduce Brian Garrett
Brian is the product manager for by
50 cabinet and ductless fume hoods he
was accredited as a LEED Green Associate
with the US Green Building Council in
2010 before joining lab conk O'Brien was
a laboratory director for the Institute
for environment environmental health
laboratory in Omaha Nebraska where he
focused on planning and management of
two labs in the beast' industry
analyzing foodborne pathogens is a
member of the controlled environment
testing association and the american
biological associate excuse me american
biological safety association
international and sits on the joint
committee for NSF ansi standard 49
please join me in welcoming Brian
Garrett I will now turn the presentation
over to him Thank You juni Thank You
laberd's for hosting us today and thanks
for tuning in to hear about how your
laboratory is sacrificing to be
sacrificing safety and spending too much
money as you said I am an expert in
laboratory ventilation and would be
we'll be talking today mostly about how
to major product groups or pieces of
equipment in your laboratory or directly
related to safety and then also how they
spend money or hit the bottom line of
your lab I'm first we're going to go
over just the general ventilation
concepts and the the difficulties are
being faced with decades-old design
systems we're talk about specifically
high efficiency or high performance fume
hoods biological safety especially where
it mixes with chemical safety new
paradigms in ventilation safety design
of the laboratory and how all of these
affect your budget so we will look at
these them from several different
business cases first looking at high
efficiency fume hoods and ventilation if
you are in the process of designing a
new laboratory you need to keep in mind
that through several studies that HVAC
that is ductwork supply fans exhaust
fans the air handling units of your of
your building especially your laboratory
is going to account for approximately
60% of the cost of a new building we're
also going to look at how these fume
hoods interact with those exhaust
systems so a traditional ducted fume
hood is simply a neighborly pressurized
enclosure that takes the hazard papers
away from the user and then through to
the outside this is the concept where
the solutions pollution is dilution a
fume hood should not be installed
without first considering whether the
laboratories supply air system so now
you need to get mechanical engineers
involved will be able to replace all of
the air that it's exhausting for proper
hood operation and these are safety
there must be sufficient air in the
laboratory to exhaust and achieve the
face velocity required so on on the
slide you see there are several terms
here that we use space velocity is your
linear speed that is what is directly
impacting the safety that the design of
the hood or biosafety cabinet provides
volume or Sabah's metric rate of air
moved or the flow of air through a fume
hood and then out of the building this
is where we get into the budgetary side
of selecting proper ventilation and fume
hoods and they are directly related
where the size of the hood with the face
velocity of the space or the speed of
air is equal to that volumetric rate
that exhausted air does cost money as
we'll talk about later in the
presentation we also need to understand
the components of a fume hood system you
have the fume hood itself keep in mind
the fume hood is nothing more than
really just a box with a front opening
in a hole in the top to move air through
you also have a work surface a base
cabinet then you have the ductwork that
connects the fume hood to the remote
blower or air handling unit that's
typically roof-mounted or put in an
engineering interstitial space we also
have to have an exhaust translation
translate
termination we call these whether caps
and they have to be open on the top so
as not to retrain chemically
contaminated or Laden air back into
either return systems or supply systems
for the building I'm or on two buildings
next door you also have to look at the
idea of fume hood placement and this
again goes for any piece of equipment
that moves there for safety whether it's
a safety of the operator or the safety
or purity of the product being handled
inside of the enclosure we want to avoid
hallways windows supply air sources and
other equipment that move air typically
you want three to six inches between
hoods and you want them as far away from
traffic ways walkways or any potential
open windows as you can there are two
main types of mechanical systems there's
a constant air volume system which is
the most simple is really ideal for
small laboratories or specialty
applications those are applications that
are very very hazardous even to your
operators and personnel or to actual
building materials so you can talk about
acid digestion x'
radioisotope or work with radioactive
materials any application that requires
high heat when we say high heat
typically in the consulting world we
don't we're not talking about a Bunsen
burner or an open flame we're talking
about furnaces again acid digestion
where your heating potential acids or
other solvents or materials up to four
or five hundred degrees those would be
hiking regardless these concentrator
systems are constantly exhausting if the
name implies the same volumetric rate of
air and imagine the position of the sash
height therefore as you raise or lower
the statue were directly impacting the
face velocity and therefore the safety
in front of the enclosure variable air
systems are variable air volume systems
also known as VAD s are really coming
into
play especially on large laboratories
large buildings and integrated systems
because they are more efficient and
download life of the time the life of
the building or laboratory can save
money and energy the way these systems
work is that the volume of air pulled
through the hood or through another
device is going to change as you lower
or raise the sash so you maintain
velocity at the face of the hood
what your change but you're rolling or
raising the volume this is really good
when you lower the sash because now it's
basically in a resting position as
opposed to running 100% the entire time
here you see what a fume hood installed
with a variable air volume system looks
like the exact same hood but there is a
mechanical electromechanical damper or
valve installed above the hood as the
sash is raised to his maximum height
that valve would be completely open
allowing for the full maximum volume of
air flow flowing through the hood as you
lower the sash all the way to a near
closed position you have a damper that
will close with that position refresh
and now instead of using the full board
purposes of an example 1,000 CFM you can
reduce it down to 150 or even two
hundred CFM with that closed
high-performance fume hood specifically
the hoods that were designed to save
money and energy in a laboratory were
designed they're defined as a hood that
can meet an Asscher a 110 containment
test and must do so with a 60 feet per
minute face velocity with the sash all
the way open the majority of North
America's safety recommendations require
hoods to operate between 60 and 100 feet
per minute face velocity if you are in
the state of California you're required
to be at a minimum of 100 so even though
you have a high performance fume hood
that can contain at the numbers we're
talking about here you still have to
operate that hood at 100 feet per minute
so to manufacture or design a
high-performance fume hood for safety
you have to meet a very stringent test
at the hood weakest point and most
energy inefficient points meaning that
you're exhausting the highest amount of
airflow with the sash as wide open as
possible we're also having a face
velocity that's a lot lower than most
people would primarily recommend those
are more you have to detect point 0 1
ppm on a sulfur hexafluoride detector
test so when you compare a
high-performance fume hood to a 6-foot
typical hood you can see below the two
examples out of blood compost product
lines when operating for optimal savings
so you're now operating with a typical
6-foot hood would at a hundred feet per
minute is going to give you 11 hundred
CFM of exhaust and we're going to get
into the numbers of this here
momentarily but a six foot high
performance fume hood will operate with
the same level of safety but at 450 CFM
using sixty feet per minute it's
important to note here that every 150
CFM is equal to approximately one ton of
air conditioning if you're designing
you're budging for a new building or a
retrofit that one ton of air
conditioning is gonna cost roughly
$2,000 so in this example you have the
savings of 650 CFM which is equal to
four point three tons or eight thousand
seven hundred dollars in air
conditioning cost per hood if you look
at all the other pieces to install this
where you have heating cooling air
exchange ductwork etc it's closer to
sixteen thousand dollars per six foot
hood there are many institutions that
have upwards of a thousand to fifteen
hundred fume hoods installed by
switching from a typical fume hood that
was the general technology up until
normal 1990s into what is really now the
the prime of high-performance hood
design you're talking about savings of
tens of millions of dollars if you have
to be slightly more conservative you
still want to run a high-performance
fume hood at 100 feet per minute instead
of the prescribed 60 you're still saving
400 CFM so if you work out the math
there's still a high degree of savings
and the number this is all upfront costs
does not include the fume hood
going to the math of actual now lifetime
savings so if you calculate out the
savings of just going to a lower flow
fume hood you can now also look at how
much air you're going to exhaust or
remove from the building and look at the
different degrees of savings you have on
that far right-hand column so just going
from a typical fume hood to a
high-performance u hood and operating
them in the exact same manner is going
to start give you improved safety
because they're tested to a higher
safety factor and you're going to get
lifetime energy savings but it's going
to be modest if you have a capability of
running that height that same high
performance fume hood at a reduced face
velocity on a variable air system
you can now say over $100,000 per hood
we didn't talk about but also on this
chart that are filtered view parts this
is a higher designed hood that is not
connected to ductwork it uses high-grade
carbon filtration technology and
chemical detection and you don't have to
connect it to a mechanical system so now
your savings over entire hood are going
to be offset by the cost of filters that
need to be purchased to replace
exhausted filters that are loaded with
chemicals we can see there are also the
lifetime savings of those hoods against
your your typical six-foot fume hood
next we're gonna talk about biological
safety and the purpose of much of this
material is actually going to be
biological safety can and/or
contaminated combined with chemical
safety because that's where the the
biggest advances and in movement of the
industry is going we look at the
differences between a different class
two biosafety cabinet specifically and
then overall how laboratories to move to
a more flexible design to reduce cost of
ownership and in some cases increase
safety here you see the type-a cabinets
these are the workhorses of the modern
microbiological laboratory you'll also
see them often in pharmacy
pharmaceutical research compounding
pharmacy Forensic Sciences in clinical
laboratories clinical both clinical
research and clinical testing type-a
cabinets have a lot of internal and
external recirculation and in fact they
were designed primarily to be
restricting their air back in the
laboratory however when you're dealing
with nuisance chemicals nuisance levels
or odors you can put a canopy on top of
them and exhaust those so that you're
not putting those odors or sensitizing
chemicals back in the laboratory one of
the most famous examples or applications
for this is
in the clinical settings where they're
handling fecal matter and urine samples
those are orders you don't really want
to be going back into the laboratory the
pros of class to type a cabinet is that
they're flexible
meaning that they can be installed
pretty much anywhere especially if
they're not going to be ducted and when
they are can't be connected they have
low exhaust demands and therefore are
much more suitable for manifold ador
systems that use one blower for multiple
hoods the biggest downfall of these
designs is that they're not convertible
so you can never flip a switch on an a2
and now be able to handle hazardous
chemistry and you don't have chemical
protection to begin with in the mid
early 1980s a new biosafety cabinet was
was requested by NIH and in the safety
community where they wanted to have
biological safety and also be able to
handle hazardous chemistry this really
started with originally with radioactive
tagging of tissue samples but then also
moved into things like tuberculosis
testing where they do you work with
hazardous acid gases both of these
cabinets the type these are connected to
an independent dedicated exhaust system
so it's great for providing that same
chemical protection kind of as a hybrid
between a class 2 bio cabinet in the
chemical fume hood however because
they're directly or hard have a hard
connection to the exhaust system there
are a slave to their installation they
are not flexible they consume a high
amount of energy because they exhaust a
lot of air and like I said they have a
dedicated require a dedicated exhaust
system and that really ratchets up the
demand on the the facility and its
infrastructure however as I said they do
offer that chemical protection by using
single pass airflow
new to NSF and to the classy biological
safety cabinet is a class two type C
biosafety cabinet this cabinet uses a
mixture of recirculated and exhausted
airflow and has internal construction or
design using internal blowers and
separate ductwork to what it can either
recirculate like an A or if it's
connected to an exhaust system with
single pass airflow it can provide
protection against low levels of
hazardous chemistry so it does provide
chemical protection it is flexible I'll
show in a moment how it reduces its cost
of operation and furthermore this new
cabinet offers safety during and beyond
operational system failure looking at
class to exhaust systems you're going to
see a very similar parts and put pieces
as you'd find on a fume hood you have
the enclosure itself you have a create a
transition connection of some sort the
ductwork the blower and then finally a
weather cap looking with traditional
biosafety cabinet resources that were
available you can see the exhaust volume
parameters of A's and B's you can see
that the a2 is exhausting roughly half
of what you find in a class to type d2
situation which is the preferred type B
that you'll see around the world we also
have differences in pressures and if you
were talking to anyone that was sizing
the mechanical system you would see in
here that's a very important number when
it comes to the design in installation
and operation of these these systems
basically what you're looking at when
you have a larger number it makes it
much more difficult to balance multiple
devices on the same air handling unit
whereas on a lower pressure number that
doesn't change just like a fume hood you
can have 10 or 20 of those cabinets on
the same blower that adds efficiency to
the design of a building and
uses repetition in both purchase parts
and installations so we had a queued up
for you several videos going here
forward kind of talking about some of
these these differences in the design
system we're going to push out or
they've already pushed out the videos
for some of these the first one is a
video that talks about flexibility of
the c1 and shows how simple and easy it
is once you buy this cabinet to be able
to change it from what we call an a mode
to a b mode and what that does is it
offers a laboratory debated to purchase
one one box one cabinet and be able to
use it as the needs and designs the
cabinet change so you may not be using
hazardous chemistry in your research and
therefore you have it just recirculating
and then all of a sudden your test
you're provided a new task and now you
have to introduce you know applications
or processes that involve formaldehyde
or or designing or something that
benzene those kinds of chemicals where
we need chemical protection you recall
you cannot convert an a to of being get
that chemical safety this cabinet has
that capability and vice versa so you're
able to increase flexibility and say to
you be able to decrease the upfront
spend of your laboratory redesign we
will look at the cost of ownership and
specifying BSC s type B's as I very said
require the cup multiple small
independent exhaust systems per cabinet
in addition to the centralized exhaust
of the laboratory or other hoods and
type a bio cabinets that base do not
require this level of design nor do they
offer the customer the safety the B's
the type c1 simplifies this selection
process it could be designed into a
building just as a few hundred type
eight cabinet can when it comes to the
exhaust systems and when once an
operation the type C is going to
continue save ninety for you or the
laboratory
even pay them back compared to a b2
you're looking about 550 thousand
dollars per cabinet saved over 15 years
and upfront a savings of around 12
thousand dollars not including the
cabinet itself so in this next video
you'll see you can take a chance to
watch it it shows how that chemical
safety is achieved by generating two
internal but independent airflow systems
within the cabinet you're able to
basically splice the air that's being
moved and provide a single pass air flow
for your chemical-laden air which also
makes it a lot easier for training users
and this is where the safety comes in
for certain if you're handling or you're
providing training and how to safely
handle biological agents and chemical
agents in a class 2 biosafety cabinet
looking at a tooms first the blue work
surface indicates where you can use
biological hazards but not chemical
hazards so the HU is very simple to
train in do not use hazardous chemistry
or hazardous chemicals in the cabinet
the entire unit can be used for
biological hazards likewise a class to
type b2 is also very simple to train in
the red indicates where chemical hazards
can be used the b1 which is a legacy
design this kind of was the first
attempt at a hybrid between a total
exhausted cabinet like the b2 and the a2
which was the preliminary recirculating
design here you can see the training
becomes a little bit more difficult as
does the factor of safety where the red
or the rear of the work zone is we can
safely handle chemicals and that's
because in these cabinets they have two
independent exhaust systems but their
entry is not delimited
with the front of a cabinet that air is
recirculated so that air will will be
recirculated back into the cabinet if
you're using hazardous chemistry you
don't want to concentrate those chemical
vapors in the work zone in the middle
like haven't you see a zone of purple
and that's because as the filters load
in the class two cabinet as it's used
throughout the day in operation the line
of where the air goes to an exhausted
mode versus a recirculating actually
moves backwards and forwards so unless
you are actually introducing smoke into
the area you don't know where that line
of safety actually is the type c1 makes
this far more easy to identify and
comfortable to work in it does use a
three-part work surface on the current
designs and the central area that is
dished and perforated right in front of
an operator where they're sitting and
where they're going to be actively
working is where you can use hazardous
chemistry if the cabinet deducted so for
this this diagram we're assuming the
cabinet deducted in the B mode and
exhausting the contaminated air flow if
it's recirculating the entire work zone
would be below no has this chemistry
would be allowable so for the purpose of
training users and how to safely use the
cabinet's a diagram like this would say
if you have this kind of a cabinet where
it's red you can use hazard chemistry
where it's blue you can use only micro
hazards microbiological samples
is that our lip service
lady service so in this video you are
able to see smoke introduced to the work
surface or into the work zone and show
the line of containment in that central
area that smoke was contained and did
not drift out to the edges why fart org
as opposed to the smoke that's
introduced on the far edges will
actually bleed back into the internal
zone what that showing is the
containment of that zone that
high-velocity area that's providing that
chemical protection in the next video
you'll see a challenge where 30 liters
per minute or vapor are produced above
that Kim's own and what you want to look
for is the lack of smoke leaving that
area or out the front of the hood
[Music]
in their future
[Music]
yes
last video is actually looking at how
the axiom or sorry the type c1 provides
protection beyond chemical or beyond a
system failure of the building so say
you have a microbiologist working in
front of the cabinet
they've got hazardous biologicals and
hazardous chemistry inside of the
cabinet for some of the other different
for the other types of cabinets if that
exhaust system were to fail say there's
a blower on the roof it throws a it
blows over broad the blower stops
operating they have to alarm within a
set amount of time and worst case
scenario your your cabinet loses
containment best-case scenario the
cabinet just goes to dead air and now
safety is completely placed upon the
shoulders of the operator in front of
the cabinet the axiom or the texting one
seems to improve that safety beyond just
that in beyond that failure so we're not
talking about an electrical system
failure where everything dies but when
the mechanical part fails the type c1
has the ability following or pending a
risk assessment making sure that no
other parts of the building's exhausts
or safety are affected to continue to
operate and provide that same velocity
of airflow through the front of the
cabinet and the down flows are still
providing protection for your operator
and your product in the work zone doing
so actually allows you to write more
specific emergency protocols for
operators to maintain their safety
oftentimes if you look at the safety
protocols during an emergency failure of
a fume hood the operators are told and
the human alarm goes off they must exit
the facility or exit the building of the
laboratory biosafety cabinet operators
don't have that luxury oftentimes
they're all we're dealing with
chain-of-custody
they have to maintain assets their
biologicals or samples they're the
organisms whatever they're working with
those those infectious
go skeet just be left in the dead air
situation in the biological safety
cabinet so what this looks to do is
provide an extra level of safety for
them while they finish their work based
on materials wrap that up and maintain
that chain of custody to get it to an
incubator or a safe place before they
themselves we've all the while being
protected other biological safety
cabinets under such a failure don't
necessarily offer that same level of
protection or they do for the biological
but not the chemical side the type c1
bridges that gap and allows for true
chemical safety
so in summary what we want to look at is
what the class two types c1 BS you can
do to harmonize both safety and cost
savings it does that by being flexible
meaning can change from an a mode to a B
mode when it's ducted it has the same
energy savings as other non ducted
systems or ducted systems that aren't
using total mass airflow it reduces cost
by 50% on the lifetime it can reduce
upfront cost by more than more than the
price of the cabinet itself and then
also for those of us that are dealing
risk assessment in determining
calculations based on how much is how
much chemistry state chemistry versus
hazardous chemistry can work with on the
open bench do I need a fume hood all
those questions the class of the new c1
can actually simplify that selection
process by providing a cabinet that
could handle pretty much any chemical or
biological hazard thrown at it that can
hand based on materials of construction
I thank you for taking the time out of
your day to review this material and
learn more about safety and saving money
in your laboratory
Thank You T thank you Brian for that
informative presentation it's time for
Q&A if you have a question you'd like to
ask for and Garrett please do so now
just click on the green Q&A button at
the lower left of the presentation
window type your question into the box
that appears on the screen and click on
the send button well answer as many of
your questions as we have time for so
let's get started our first question is
we are in the process of planning a new
lab how can my team evaluate and
calculate the ROI for a standard fume
hood versus one of the high performance
hood you talked about thank you gee
that's an excellent question when we the
calculations I provided on the lifetime
operating costs or the return on
investment that you'd be looking at we
use a median average for energy costs
looking at different power ratings
dollars or cents per kilowatt-hour and
roughly they calculate out to $8 per CFM
per year so if you want to judge or I
guess compared different hoods whether
they're two different high efficiency
hoods between two different competitors
or you want to compare different hood
types within the same manufacturer if
you want to get an idea of how much that
fume hood or biosafety cabinets going to
cost over 15 years or over a year even
just multiply the difference in volume
by $8 per CFM per year and that's going
to give you your savings thanks to the
hood seem to be operating at the same
airspeed how is a high-performance hood
actually safer now another fabulous
question so what we're looking at our
methods and designs where the hoods are
actually designed for for more efficient
air movement so some designs utilize air
air foils at the front of the hood that
move air foil through them in a cleaner
manner so you don't have to worry about
just mass airflow it's actually more of
a laminar sweeping motion of air in some
cases you have baffles that are slotted
the baffle being the back wall of the
hood is slotted to promote even flow of
air even flow of air through the hood
there are a lot of small nuanced details
that can get a hood to more efficiently
use that air flow and more efficiently
you move the air through an enclosure
the lower the velocity or volume can be
achieved the same level of safety so
while we do not advocate at all for the
operating in hoods below 60 feet per
minute many of today's high-performance
fume hoods meet the same safety criteria
operated at 50 feet per minute or even
40 feet per minute and what that shows
is that should something catastrophic
happened to the hood the exhaust system
the depth of the ductwork the damper any
of that
you have a high degree of safety that's
built into the hood even if you're
operating at 100 feet per minute you can
now drop all the way down to 60 50 40
and still have some degree of safety
that before you wouldn't have had on a
typical fume hood which limited grant
money what is in it for me in my labs
came more for a convertible biosafety
cabinet what there's there's no question
that the way of our laboratories are
funded today make it far more difficult
to to buy the the luxury or the the
convertible this or that so we're in
faced with limited money you have to
decide between purchasing equipment and
paying people salaries your technicians
or paying for more critical consumable
equipment there's no doubt that there
has to be some gauge there on what you
can do the best thing I recommend is
looking not just at what you're going to
be doing immediately for the next but
for this study or the next study but
work 3 4 or 5 10 years down the road and
save yourself you know what what do I
plan on doing what do I want to do with
my science where can this possibly take
me and if there's going to be a mix of
sciences chemistry and biology together
anywhere down the road you know
significant savings can be had by
purchasing the product that's going to
survive 15 years and provide that
flexibility so what's your what you're
doing is instead of delaying a cost down
the line the price to biosafety cabinets
aides B's and C's are all within a
couple thousand dollars of each other
but can cost as much as ten fifteen
thousand so you can yeah you could buy
an A now for ten thousand dollars and
move down the future if you need to be
that may have to change and now you're
out another fifteen thousand dollars
with grant money that may or may not be
there at that time so what's your what
you're getting is flexibility and peace
of mind that whatever hazards are going
to creep into my laboratory I'll be able
to handle something to have that
flexibility I would like to once again
thank
Ryan Garrett for his presentation do you
have any final comments I I don't
believe so I thank you all again for
taking your time every day to spend with
us great well thanks once again I would
also like to thank our sponsor Alaskan
Co for making today's educational
webcast possible this webinar has been
approved for continuing educational
credits please click on the CTE button
at the bottom left corner and follow the
process to receive your credits before
we go I want to let everyone know that
today's webcast will be available for
on-demand viewing through December 29th
2017 you'll receive an email from lab
relating you know when your webcast will
be available for replay please share
that announcement with your colleagues
whom you've missed today's live event
that is all for now thank you for
joining us we hope to see you again soon
goodbye